[Music]
hello we're currently in the middle of
our break between seasons four and five
but we wanted to do a quick video to
remind everyone or tell everyone
depending on whether you knew or not
that our master of microscopes james
weiss has a book out it's wonderful it's
called the hidden beauty of the
microscopic world and it is available
online through most major booksellers
james is the person responsible for all
of the beautiful images you see on your
screen every single week in fact the
ones you are seeing right now are just a
little sneak peek at some of our
upcoming season 5 episodes and in his
book you'll be able to not only look
through a bunch of james's amazing
images but you can also read more about
the microbes themselves and about his
personal journey through the microcosmos
it's a beautiful book and it can give
you another way to get to know our micro
friends and our master of microscopes a
little bit better so we're going to be
back next week with a brand new episode
but for now you can catch up on our
videos from last season by checking out
our season 4 playlist and don't forget
to pick up the hidden beauty of the
microscopic world wherever you get your
books or at the link in the description